bienvenue à cet exercice naval
international contact surface non
identifiés à 4 nautique
ça fait partie de l'exercice
probablement
je veux que vous alliez l'inspecter de
près on envoie une équipe tout de suite
j'y vais je crois pas que ce soit une
bonne idée j'ai compris et chef
artois de la leis
ça craint merci
disait qu'il viendrait
quand les déjà tout seul
et qu'un jour on tomberait sur deux
ou que tomberait sur nous où est le
capitaine il est mort vieux qui est
souvent grave c'est vous
ils ont créé une sorte de bouclier il
sembla pénétrable nous avons trois
destroyers portées disparues peut-être
quelqu'un puisse infiltrés quels sont
vos sabres ont leur antre de temps
qu'est ce qui nous fait peur
continue à tirer